بعد اصابه العديد من طلاب المدارس خلال
الفتره القليله الماضيه حضر وزير الصحه
والسكان المصري من سرعه انتشار الفايروس
المخلويه التنفسي وزير الصحه قال لان طفلا
واحدا مصابا بالفيروس قد يتسبب في عدوى
للمجموعه بالكامل في المدرسه سواء عن طريق
الرذاذ او التلامس مطالبا اولياء الامور
بعدم ارسال اي طفل مصاب للمدرسه لان نسبه
انتشار الفيروس مرتفعه الفايروس المخلويه
التنفسي هو مجموعه من الفيروسات المخاطيه
التي من الممكن ان تتسبب في بعض الحالات
مثل التهابات شديده في الجهاز التنفسي
وتتسلل الى الجهاز التنفسي عند الاطفال
والاشخاص البالغين وفقا لوزاره الصحه ليس
هناك مضاد حيوي معالج لهذا الفايروس ولا
لقاح مضاد للاصابه به وهذا يرجع للتطور
السريع لسطح الفايروس ولكن يمكن الوقايه
منه من خلال اتباع بعض الاجراءات
الاحترازيه التي تتمثل في غسل اليدين
الاماكن المغلقه والتوقف عن تقبيل الاطفال
[موسيقى]